each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
city of Virginia Cameron is certainly no
stranger to this part of the world he
got his PhD from the University of
Washington and has visited us a number
of times today Kevin's going to come and
talk to us about aspect-oriented
programming or whether we really need
aspects respecto at programming so as is
typical I Kevin this ripping off his PhD
students excuse me work now I just
kidding thanks thanks yeah you know it's
the price of doing business with faculty
members have them rebuff good so this
work really comes out of a mostly
National Science Foundation funded
effort to try to understand this
phenomenon of aspect-oriented
programming it's an interesting it's an
interesting area because you know
there's a lot going on conferences
substantial industry buying and so on
and so forth there's some things that
are evidently not right about the story
we're being told but then there's some
other stuff about it that's pretty
interesting so the NSF basically hired
me and my colleague bill Griswold at
UCSD to you know try to sort it all out
and that's what we've been that's what
we've been looking at so all of this
work really centers around the the issue
of modularity in design that is the
fundamental the fundamental issue and of
course this this topic goes way back to
Dijkstra's notion of separation of
concerns to concepts of abstraction and
information hiding and so on and so
forth and the story that the
aspect-oriented programming folks are
telling early centers on improvements in
our ability to design software with
respect to these concerns with expected
payoffs in terms of improved
understandability and trustworthiness
parallel development time-to-market ease
of change giving us the ability to
produce more variety in our software at
at less cost so the the the the story
that we're told in by the
spect oriented community is that our
prevailing approaches to separating
concerns to modularizing designs really
are are inadequate by prevailing design
approach we generally mean those
approaches that are roughly
object-oriented in one way or another
we're talking about objects components
web services all of these sorts of
approaches that Center on you know api's
the story is that modularizing systems
in this way is inadequate from for
separating out some important concerns
that arise in in practice and that arise
increasingly in the kinds of systems
that we're trying to build today and
that the consequence of these
inadequacies is that we end up with with
poor modularity and in particular we we
hear these terms fragmented and
scattered and tangled tangled code so i
got interested in this area because a
its influential there's significant
research going on there's lots of
industrial buy-in at this point
significant endorsements from places
like IBM it's hot in the developer
community on the other hand it's a
controversial area early projections of
benefits were really quite unrealistic
you know 11 joke goes that you write
your base coat and then you write pound
safety and suddenly you know you have
safe safe base code in other words you
add a safety aspect for safety or at a
security aspect for security those
projections probably were overly
optimistic aop also kind of questions
some tenets of good software design in
particular it tends to violate
modularity and abstraction in some
important ways and it challenges
certainly or can challenge our ability
reason about the behaviors of the
systems that we build um so the kinds of
problems that we see in in current
aspect oriented languages or these and
I'm just going to review them really
briefly we look at aspect languages
today we find a programming models that
we believe are overly complex leading to
program designs that are overly complex
system architectures are overly
constrained which is to say you can only
build aspect oriented systems in certain
ways today
and um and and those are the problems
that i intend to talk about addressing
today so the rest of this talk is
structured roughly as follows for those
who are not kind of in the know I'll
briefly give you the story on what a 0 P
is for a brief introduction to aspectj
which is by really by far the most
influential model of aspect-oriented
programming today and then I'll identify
a couple of key problems with the
aspectj like model and tell you about
how we solve them I'll identify a couple
of important asymmetries in the design
of the aspectj language model show you
how they lead to some problems in terms
of our ability to separate certain kinds
of concerns and how they lead to fragile
and overly constrained structures and
time permitting i'll get to this last
question what about obliviousness
obliviousness being a term that arises
frequently in the aspect oriented world
yeah the high level does aspect are
deeper going to assume that object or
you are a mean is sort of you know the
right model and built on it I mean is
there is there a way to separate the two
are they completely unconnected
let's see in in principle there's not
that assumption but in practice there is
that assumption which is to say that
almost all of the work going on in that
community assumes an underlying object
oriented model certainly ask that today
in all of language is that a like it
assume an object oriented model and then
basically add some reflective stuff on
top that allows you to to refactor
things in certain new kinds of ways so I
think for all practical purposes it's
reasonable to basically say it's an it's
an extension of the oo model okay so
first section of the talk what is that
aao for the the basic notion is that
when it comes to implementing certain
kinds of concerns in software like an
execution tracing policy or cross module
optimizations or use of thread pools or
security policy enforcement or code to
integrate the behaviors of separate
components that we often end up with
code that looks like this okay where
there's some kind of base code that's
the black code to do what you want to
get done and then there's some scattered
around bits of blue code to accomplish
or to implement these other concerns if
for example you want to do procedure
call tracing it would be very common to
include code all over the place to
output trace messages that would be the
blue code a problem is that now when you
want to change the policy for how you
trace procedure calls changing the
selection of calls to trace for example
you may need to dig up lots of code in
order to to make those sorts of changes
so the consequences of this kind of
scattering and committing of of code for
cross-cutting concerns is is expected
really to lead to bad consequences in
terms of more faulty software broken
deadlines and increased costs to build
and change to build and change systems
so a 0 P fundamentally claims to provide
improved abilities to to modularize code
and in particular to modularize the kind
of blue code that tends to be scattered
around a system if one is using a
straightforward object-oriented approach
okay so aop going to your question
generally extends object oriented
languages with new mechanisms to allow
for modular ization of cross-cutting
concerns so that really is the kind of
key phrase at the heart of that
community to enable better modular
ization of cross-cutting concerns and
the way that it works is to allow in
some sense for one module the module
that's going to hold all the blue code
some sense to modify the behavior of
other modules in the system in
potentially very intrusive ways okay so
that's where some of the some of the
controversy arises so the idea then in
aop is that instead of writing code that
looks like this with the blue stuff all
over the place using these new
mechanisms you want to write write your
code like this the black code is
generally referred to as base code the
blue code is now modularized localized
in one place and is referred to as
aspect code so let me just stream so
when you say modular you mean basically
what you just said it's localized in one
place not that it's self-contained
provides an abstraction a module in the
classic sense well at a minimum at a
minimum that it is textually lexically
in terms of the physical architecture
localized in one place now you'll get
arguments as to whether aspects support
abstraction you know take logging policy
for example you have a policy for which
execution events in a program you want
to log if all of the code that sort of
implements a particular policy is
localized in one place then in fact that
module could be claimed to abstract the
logging policy but in some sense then it
destroyed the modularity of the other
things because they're not localized in
place anymore it destroyed the
modularity of the other stuff of these
code because you can't look at the news
code and see was
much
to the side aha so by removing the blue
code from the black code you make it
harder to understand what's going to
happen in terms of the execution trace
when the black code runs right yeah
that's right that's right do we do that
all the time when we factor out
procedures or refactor class hierarchies
or any other time pull out some piece of
code that might be called implicitly or
explicitly right I'm just don't
understand what the word modular I
already means well I mean it's it's an
excellent question right i mean because
one set 11 notion of modularity is just
lexical another notion of modularity has
to do with the design process that
different teams can be responsible for
developing different pieces of a system
and for doing it relatively
independently because there's some kind
of agreement that decouples them and
that guarantees that their resulting
bits of code will integrate i'll get
back to that later and then there's sort
of semantic notions of modularity in
terms of ability to reason about what
happens based on some local piece of
code so you know the answer I think to
your question is it depends you know
exactly which which which form of
modularity you're talking about
kids question I'm thinking you know does
it affect my ability to reason about you
know broadly across the system you know
what's happening and you know in other
words each module I have this extra
thing you have to look at so is it
really changed globally the notion of
what you know what you need to know uh
it seems like it hasn't d created this
one I think about stretching I think of
decreasing complexity right I need to
know less too you know okay well I mean
so the quaint the claim is that the
people who are writing the black code do
in fact need to know less because the
people who are writing this module here
they don't necessarily want to know what
somebody else's policy is for how
execution of their code is going to be
logged or traced okay so to the extent
that they can forget about it
successfully do that I guess that's the
question that well that is the question
that really bet that that's really the
heart of the matter and I'll come back
to that again at the at the end of the
talk okay so that's that's the goal of
aspect-oriented programming to allow
that kind of modular ization and the way
it happens is that code in a third
module can in some sense intrude into
the behavior of other pieces of your
system so the next part of the talk here
is a kind of an introduction to aspectj
and really this is meant to to give you
a clear sense of the mechanisms by which
this new kind of modular ization becomes
possible so there are four key
mechanisms that you have to understand
really to have a reasonable sense of
what aspectj is about join points
pointcuts advice and finally aspects and
the aspect is a particular kind of
module okay so join points are points in
program execution where you might want
one of these third-party aspects to come
in and change the behavior of that that
would happen otherwise point cuts are
essentially predicates that serve to
pick out subsets of join points so I
could for example write a pointcut
expression that picked out all calls to
all methods within some piece of my
system
or I could write a different point cut
descriptor that would pick out all calls
to all methods whose names start with
set that would be a different a
different predicates picking out a
different set of join points okay advice
is essentially an anonymous procedure
body and the idea is that you're going
to take a one of these anonymous
procedures or advice and bind it to all
of the join points that are picked out
by a given point cut descriptor okay so
aspectj allows you to say here's a
here's a predicate that picks out all
calls to all methods in this package
that begin with the word set point cut
descriptor picks out a set of join
points and then within an aspect you can
say at each such join point i want the
following piece of code to run okay so
at any call to any method within this
package run this code that outputs a
message saying this procedure was called
for example that would be a way of in a
local lexically local way of
implementing a particular policy about
how to how to trace procedure calls in a
in a piece of a system finally then an
aspect is a class like module that in
addition to doing what normal classes
can do for the most part with in which
one can also declare pointcut
expressions and bind advice to join
points okay so an aspect is like a class
except that it can do these other it can
do some of these other advising
activities and the notion of aop then is
that in order to modularize
cross-cutting concerns you right aspects
what it's the advice is encode does it
executes yes its coat so and so it's
coated that speaks about the lexical
structure of the code that it's modified
of the joint point yeah look I'll give
you a difficult great example or up well
I don't want to interrupt your concrete
example but I had a more general point
that I'm hoping you're going to get to
okay this it's one of my confusions
about aspects which is is
aspect-oriented programming inherently
metaprogramming it seems like when I'm
making when I'm trying to isolate design
decisions that are about the problem to
be solved that's where your classic
Parnis modules come in and it seems like
these this new kind of modularity that
we're trying to achieve somehow seems to
be inherently about the program itself
and not so much about you know the
solution to customers problems right
like the classic examples always tend to
be things like you know logging error
handling blah blah but you know I can't
even tell you what the decision is
without talking about there being a
program and yet I'm going to do the
program yeah I'll let the cat out of the
bag a little bit i mean i think the
answer to your question is no okay
although it's usually talked about in
that way okay okay but really when you
get right down to it will you have are
some new programming mechanisms that
allow you to make something happen when
something else happens which is just
like procedure call you know when this
call happens this thing over here
supposed to run well now when this piece
of code is executed something else over
here runs or runs instead or runs before
or runs after so in sometimes you can
demystify a lot of this stuff by
forgetting about all of the the
meta-level stuff and just understanding
it as numeric new programming mechanisms
new ways of making two pieces of code
integrate and compile into a binary that
runs okay so this is a this is a piece
of code a little sensor class and it has
a data member signal of type boolean and
a method detect which gets called when
the sensor detects a signal in and the
detect method sets the signal data
member to true okay so there are a
couple of different join points that you
could talk about in this piece of code
one would be the call any call to the
detect method one would be the execution
of the detect method
body here's a joint point the set of a
data member okay so these are joined
points in the aspectj model one can now
write point cut descriptors that say
well when the signal data member of the
sensor class is set cause some piece of
code to run in an aspect somewhere okay
here is in fact a pointcut descriptor
relative to that simple example this
point cut descriptor says all of the
join points and there's only one here at
which the detect method if the sensor
class actually begins to execute okay
and there are other point cut
descriptors in aspect jakes so you can
talk about all calls to methods
execution of method bodies reads and
writes of data members you can constrain
the selection of join points using
within so you can say all calls within
some package off all calls that occur
within the dynamic scope of some other
call that is the what the sea flow a
pointcut constructor is for and so on
and so forth okay
and one can use pattern matching
constructs in in these at this point in
a pointcut descriptor so you could say
public void star dot detect and that
would be any execution of any method
called detect in any class okay now the
idea is you by advising that point cut
descriptor you cause things to happen
you essentially add behavior to your
system in a way that is independent of
the the ordinary class hierarchy so
here's a piece of advice then building
on our example this says before the
execution of sensor dot detect click a
camera okay so the idea here is that you
want to write a piece of code that that
that has the effect that when the sensor
detects a signal some camera gets
triggered okay to take a picture of some
detected phenomenon so here's a piece of
a piece of an aspect that would do that
before any execution of sensor detect
tell some camera to take a picture and
so in this way one in some sense adds a
side effect to the detect method causing
a camera to be clicked and then here is
the the aspect module itself that would
wrap up all that code as a si si as a
module constructing aspectj aspect is a
keyword sensor cameras the name of the
key aspect has data members a sensor in
a camera declares a pointcut called
detects detects comprises that set of
join points described here the execution
of sensor dot detect and then this is a
piece of advice it says before any of
these join points in other words just
before sensor dot detect execute tell
the camera to take a picture
yes
the this this is an aspect that a little
type of their this is an aspect whose
purpose is to integrate the behavior of
a sensor component and a camera
component such that when the sensor
detects a signal a camera gets triggered
I'm asking for specific question was it
to ourselves senator yeah that's a data
member for a moment think of this aspect
is just a class okay it when when you
construct an instance of this class you
give it a reference to a center and a
reference to a camera and the point here
then is that the the aspects as well
whenever any call is made to censor
detect assuming okay I understand so
right so we're not constraining this
piece of advice to be fired on this
particular sensor being being detecting
a signal good observation it's good yeah
so in terms of the advice here you get
before so it's pretty simply i can
imagine up after yeah there's before
after and around and okay and and
there's no other manipulation of sort of
the structure of the source you can't
say you know before and then iterate
over the statements or something like
you know i'm no i'm not in a specter so
suppose i have a follow up on Jim's
question ten senses and flinty cameras
in my program they all have different
lifetimes different scopes things like
these are breaking a lot these are great
questions let me just push it on the
stack and you'll see that in fact one of
aspect JS weaknesses is dealing with
that exact point okay regarding with you
you called demystification I mean this
very much reminds me of parallel program
composition as in the 80s right not only
that we now kind of talk about method
calls things like that as opposed to
signals or Lance be subject to
superposition right will you go your
step too far fetched I think it's okay
okay so let me just let me continue so
so here's where we begin in this the
apropos apropos of all of these comments
let me look can you come back to that at
the end and and let's go back I propose
these comments about about instances of
sensors there is actually a problem with
aspectj this is a kind of an analysis of
the relationship between classes and
aspects in aspectj what we see are that
in both classes and aspects both classes
and aspects can have fields and methods
classes unlike aspects can be
instantiated under programmer control
and can be manipulated at the instance
level so i can say new x where x is a
class and then i can do things with the
object that i created in the aspectj
programming model you declare an aspect
module but you have no control over
against the instantiation of aspects
essentially the language runtime creates
one global instance of that aspect
module and it advises
it's essentially kind of a type level
modification of your program structure
rather than an instance level
modification of your of your program
I'll make that concrete in a minute an
aspect on the other hand unlike classes
can declare pointcuts advice and there's
another constructing aspectj called
introduction that we can talk about
later if you want so in some sense
aspects and classes are kinda like each
other but they're incomparable aspects
are stronger than classes in these ways
and asked classes are stronger than
aspects in these ways aspects are more
expressive in classes in these ways
there's something weird going on here
yeah I thought aspects did have static
and dynamic flavors that they were
that's a bigger withdraw from mass spec
Jason okay there's a very there's a very
limited capability to cause multiple
instances of aspects to be created okay
it's very limited and very constraining
okay but we can put that as a footnote
okay
similarly if you look at first method
Zin advice there's kind of a weird
asymmetry they both implement procedural
abstraction zeeeee methods are named
device advices are anonymous and they
they alone can be bound to the join
point selected by by a pointcut
expression now in our analysis these
asymmetries and and non orthogonality in
the language design create a variety of
problems so the first kind of major
point of this talk is to convince you
that that there's a problem here that
the difference between aspects and
classes creates problems for programmers
it certainly doesn't satisfy kind of
abstract notions of conceptual integrity
in the design of the language and i want
to show you now concretely that it
hinders your ability to do two things
two separate integration concerns and
two separate what we call higher-order
concerns so here's your example with
multiple sensors ok it's just a scenario
this is an object diagram i have three
three sensors s1 s2 and s3 instances of
the centered sensor class two cameras c1
and c2 in a display and in this
particular application i want the
following kind of integration behavior
when the first sensor detects a signal i
want the first camera to click into the
second camera to click and i want some
other message to be displayed on some on
some other kind of advice so there's a
relationship between sensor and camera
and i have two instances of that
relationship this sensor camera
integrating relationship and I have a
different kind of relationship between
sensors and displays and one instance of
that relationship okay so is the example
reasonably clear when the sensor s1
detects a signal these other things
should happen on the side okay a simple
kind of very simple straightforward
approach that you might expect from a
student to implementing this system
would be to start with a couple of
object oriented classes and then just to
modify those classes to achieve the
required integration so to the sensor
class you add references to camera
objects to the camera objects you add
references to the sensor class to the
display you know you basically tie these
things together and you have them call
each other okay so you change the
implementation of sensor to detect so
that when a sensor detects a signal it
calls the associated camera objects a
couple of problems with this pretty
clear the the types become tightly
coupled and we end up with scattered and
tangled integration code the code
responsible for those relationships that
tie together the behaviors of cameras
and sensors are now scattered out over
the sensor and camera classes this is
probably bad students because you colors
using
okay great so students you know they
first learn about this but then they
learn about the observer pattern so then
that then they produce then they produce
they produce this solution okay they
combine the observer pattern with the
mediator pattern and they define a
sensor camera integration kind of class
a sensor camera object observes a sensor
and when the sensor notifies it of a
signal the sensor camera integration
object turns around and tells the camera
to take a picture okay and you know here
we have the announced events and there's
some code in here to register with with
with the appropriate appropriate events
and so on and so forth some problems
with this approach from the aspect or
respective are several first there's
still some scattering and tangling of
integration concerns okay if you didn't
need these behaviors to be integrated
you wouldn't necessarily have to add all
this event code all over the place okay
moreover and this gets to the second
part of the talk we might not have time
for it but this approach violates this
notion of obliviousness that the aspect
community is so has been so concerned
with what they want is for the authors
of the basecoat not to have to
anticipate the introduction of aspects
you shouldn't have to be aware when
you're writing the sensor class that
somebody might want to integrate your
behavior with a camera class okay so
that is the aspect oriented critique of
this your suggestion so
I'm either way I view it is that simply
in if you could write it this way you
have to anticipate enjoying points right
I'm actually making jumping explicit
Yorker exactly and if you write a paper
and send it to the aspect community and
it says what you said they'll send it
back and they'll say it violates the
obliviousness property because you have
to you're anticipating and what aspects
are needed now that's where there's some
difficulty with the aspect account on
the other hand you know this I think is
the big question one of the big
questions today in this whole area okay
so with that mediator based approach you
could you could you could instant you
could create two different instances of
this sensor camera class to kinect
sensor 12 camera one a different one to
connect to camera two in an instance of
this class to connect the sensor to an
instance of the display class and
everything is everything is nice and we
end up with a a runtime object structure
that looks just like this picture great
so the observation is well can't you do
even better by leveraging aspects to do
the same kind to perform the same kind
of mediating behavior but without
requiring the base coat authors to
anticipate the needs for integration
without having the need for all that
event code so then this is the notion
right here's your sensor all you do is
you introduce an ass but there's no
event code here no signaling you write
this piece of aspect code before the
sensor detects execute you call the
cameras click operation and similarly to
integrate sensor objects with the
display it sounds like it ought to work
on but there are some problems the most
the first one that pops up is that you
don't have control over aspect
instantiation and aspectj so in fact you
can't create two instances of this
aspect to connect the sensor to the
first camera into the second camera
respectively okay you don't have control
over aspect instantiation now going to
craigs point that there is some kind of
model yeah you can say you can declare
an aspect to be per target or per this
which means that you get one aspect
instance per instance of some other
class but that's not what you want here
you want two instances of this aspect
for one sensor object and that can't be
done with aspect JS / construct people
then put on an aspect
you know captures the constructor for
sensor and then builds up its own tables
of instances and then it can manage its
own perfect that's what happens right
not only can't you create can't you
create separate object set of separate
aspect instances flexibly but aspects
can't advise other objects selectively
either okay so if I say before sensor
detects I essentially get a callback
logically from this every instance of
the sensor class to this aspect instance
and it has to figure out where the
callback came from and decide what to do
with it yep
aspect facility simply to insert the
mediator and observer pattern into the
code good I'll get to that in a minute
okay so so here's an instance level view
than using aspects here are our sensors
here's our sort of one global sensor
camera integrating aspect because it
advises the sensor class it gets
callbacks every time any sensor gets
triggered and it has to figure out where
those callbacks are coming from so it
typically will do that by registering
sensors in a hash table and doing some
kind of look up and then deciding what
to do okay similarly if the aspect
advises the camera class it gets
callbacks from from from every instance
of the camera object now this is fine in
some cases but if you have one list
object in a 50 million line program and
you want to integrate it with one
instance of some otherwise you don't
want to advise every list object in your
50 million line program it's not the
right conceptual model and unless you're
very careful and I don't see how to do
it it's not very good for performance
either so here's the the instance of the
sensor display integrating object and
now what you see is that the conceptual
and probably runtime overhead increases
linearly not only in the number of
objects that are advised but in the
number of aspects that are advising them
because now when this sensor triggers
which has nothing to do with either the
camera or the display both of these
aspects get callbacks they need to do
these hash table lookups and that's the
kind of world you live in okay so it's
really just the wrong conceptual model
that's what you want and that's what you
got
so our approach really that and this is
the first half of a solution that I'll
present today is is to allow aspect now
to be instantiated under program control
and and to advise objects to advise
objects at the instance level so we've
introduced a notion of instance level
aspects you declare an aspect to be
instance level and now it can be
instantiated under programmer control
and this is the kind of code that you
can write here's your sensor class no
event signaling here's your camera class
know then signaling you create your
camera objects you instantiate your
aspects multiple times telling them
essentially to advise these objects
selectively this works ok all of this is
implemented as a really a quite complete
extension of C sharp and now you end up
having your runtime object model look
like your your logical model and and and
life is good ok so it's it's all
implemented in a language called EOS it
extends c-sharp it's a it's as
expressive as aspectj it has essentially
every feature of aspectj but it also
supports this instance level advising
okay now going to the question why don't
you just write your aspect to introduce
the the observer stuff that is this
solution right here okay so in this in
this in this figure this shows the code
implementing the full systems that I've
described here's the EOS code this is
your sensor code this is your camera
code and this is your mediating code
this is the observer approach as a
student might write it this is the
observer approach where the aspect
introduces the observer stuff into the
base code and you know I'd claim just in
terms of length which is not certainly a
perfect measure you've got it sort of
better abstraction here you've got less
code to write and you've essentially
just got a cleaner a cleaner a cleaner
picture here is that observer code
reusable observer code or specialized to
that particular observation its
specialized to that particular
observation right right absolutely it's
it's it's it's it's very special case
okay yep you criticize whether you guess
the issues in the mediator approach for
performance reasons we're just writing
the tables yourself to get some specific
well it come it under good right there
there are two costs right there's
increased design cost sure one of them
was performance and there's a
performance cost and does your
implementation that he owes solve that
so yeah ok so the trick is that what we
do under the covers is essentially
introduce delegate lists at the join
points that are selected by point cut
descriptors okay so you've got a point
cut descriptor the compiler can figure
out statically which pieces of code are
advised and what it does it under the
covers it introduces an observer kind of
structure
but it only but right and then when
aspects register with objects
selectively they register with the
delegate lists of those particular
objects so other objects that are not
advised don't they essentially have to
ask because anybody registered so it's a
test for zero that's that's where the
overhead is rod you know I was actually
going to complain that I think your your
picture on the previous slide actually
isn't very fair I want you to put
another color in there called compiler
generated code and I think that the two
rightmost columns would probably look
pretty comparable it's just that the
company owes the compiler generated a
lot of the purple gobbly from the
aspect J prime case well it might up i
mean the compiler you know our compiler
introduces delegate lists other
compilers could optimize away some of
that in lining calls and so on and so
forth the fact you know yeah harness
basically said you modular I systems in
different ways you might get the same
object code you're saying you might get
the same object code it's true you might
get the same object code but you've got
better modularity at the levels of
developer cares about okay so this this
piece is about separation of what we
call higher-order concerns so suppose
that you've now got your system where
sensors are integrated with cameras and
sensors are integrated with displays but
you decide that in some cases you want
to cache sensor signals rather than
updating cameras and displays
immediately okay so you want to be able
to turn off the propagation of signals
from sensors to cameras cash them up and
maybe propagate them along later there
are lots of applications of this kind of
this kind of pattern so what approach
that you might consider taking as well
you now you write a new aspect and what
it does is it advises the sensor camera
aspect for example so it advises around
the piece of code that causes signals to
propagate from sensor to camera so when
you advise around your code runs in
places on the line code and you can
optionally delegate back to the code
that would have run in the first place
so the idea would be right another
aspect that advises this aspect
intercepts its propagation at
and essentially cashes them it's fine
there's a problem though and the problem
is that advice bodies are anonymous in
aspectj so you can't write so so here's
here's our here's our sensor camera
integrating aspect we wrote this before
the sensor detects the signal we want
the camera to click this piece of code
has no name okay and so we can't write
another aspect that says around that
thing do something else and you know I
mean it's kind of a dumb problem and not
very deep but it's real go ahead so how
do you do stuff wrong I mean good not
just factor myself using motor neurone
apples ok so the proposal is instead of
in that that that that with what this at
piece of advice does is it simply
delegates to a real method and I wrap
that other method turns out to be
problematical okay because there's all
kinds of parameters that get that have
to be implicitly past and you have to
figure out what they are on a
case-by-case basis and if it's in a
round method you have to essentially
pass as a funk the thing that you would
proceed to call on you know it's it
turns out not to be as simple as you
would think right so the problem is you
can't say around something because the
something doesn't can't be named very
easily and this ends up limiting you to
a kind of an architectural style that is
very pervasively in the heads of the AO
folks and the style is get right your
base code and then you write your
aspects and you can't do any more than
that okay so it's sort of the notion is
we live in a world of two story
buildings we've got base code and aspect
code
obviously this focuses on the aspectj
although I am okay so fair I mean that
that fair fair enough there are people
who are looking at this but you know i
mean the aspectj model certainly is
again the most influential and your
comment notwithstanding if you talk to
aspect people they talk about base code
and aspect code there's this two-level
conceptual model of how one design
systems in this style there shouldn't
really be any difference between these
two pieces these two kinds of code they
ought you know we've got an integration
mechanism we ought to be able to use it
flexibly yep comment some concern you
know this is a letter thing already
introduces an issue with respect to
scope so you have the aspect code gets
injected and you heard of variables in
that in that scope now that code what
are the variables referring to right it
could be it in other words can you speak
about a load ville of the local
variables in the Joe add the joint point
you can't speak about you can speak
about some context but not all of it so
you can speak about the object that's
the target of the call you can't speak
about the local variables you can speak
about the the instance the data members
of a class you can't talk about the
local data race at the local variable
procedure in the in the advice code is
the is the object that's being modified
the object being modified the aspect is
modifying it remember arguments if all
arguments yeah this three layer building
how what object would that be inserted
you know the the the third story would
be advising the second story and so it
would talk about its data might so he
can never talk about the original right
and left right unless they're somehow
that it's a good point okay so so so in
the approach that in the EOS approach on
there's only methods okay named methods
and a separate method point cut binding
construct so i can say here's a point
cut here's a method now i want to bind
this method to this point cut so that
instead of writing this here's my point
cut descriptor and here's the advice i
write a method instead of the advice and
then i do this binding before these join
points essentially call
this method and now you've successfully
done what ralph was talking about you've
essentially got an advisable sort of
aspect thing so here now is what the
overall picture looks like um yeah well
just sit any of you easily apply throw
suspicion was that there are these
implicit parameters that arise in these
in this advice but how do I see those I
mean this before bits that cannot be in
order intermatic because it will have
that access to special things or is that
something you bind up there they're past
explicitly here okay and there's an
explicit thunk available to be passed at
this point okay okay so it's just
excitedly the binding chooses one of
those inputs of grammars you actually
going to use and passes an explosive
later yeah great why couldn't you just
done that together
on the left-hand side too
the body I could just say before bits
asks a bunch of arguments exactly the
arguments I would be saying and the call
before it gets it I think it might be a
good language designed to force the
program and always name these things so
they always have the opportunity to
impose later good can I come back to it
okay let me let me just see if I can add
you on here okay so so the approach that
we've basically developed then is to
take this world which is the world i
described up to this point and merge
classes and aspects and now let classes
declare pointcuts do introductions and
bind methods to pointcuts okay so
there's no longer a need for a separate
app aspect abstraction they're simply an
empowered notion of class INEOS where
classes can declare pointcut descriptors
and bind methods to point cuts
okay so now here is the code for for our
example we have a class and this is all
backward compatible now with C sharp we
have a class sensor camera references a
sensor in a camera has a method which
when called will tell the camera to take
a picture and then it has this binding
construct that declares a point cut and
finds the take picture method to those
join points yeah I still see how you
dress gents original question about the
sins
um okay so this I mean this is a piece
of alighted code you declare good
perfect um I probably left something off
you essentially you declare this on this
piece of binding to be at the instance
level okay and then there's a provided
method for essentially register causing
only those join points of a of a
specified S&C objects to be to be
advised so you're pointing to an
omission on my slide okay here's the
aspect then for the the third story of
our building and this shows the
forwarding of the thunk okay so this is
the delay aspect if delay is turned
turned off then so what we do is we
advise around the mediators method for
propagating the effect and whenever the
mediator would have clicked the camera
directly we instead call this method
this is our delegate list our funk if
you will gets passed to this method and
we write this code if we're not delaying
updates then p dinner invoke where inner
invoke is a method of this delegate
chain that essentially calls the method
that would have been called in any case
love these
aspect classes as things i instantiate
and in the constructor i pass sse the
identities of the objects which i won
absolutely that's that's a yeah and it
you know let me let me just I hate
flight slides flipping but i'll just go
back end and this is exactly the code
that you would have written okay so in
the constructor of this sensor camera
object to the constructor you pass s 1
and c 1 and it selectively advises to
join points of those particular objects
the constructor have the special
semantics because the binding it only
happens once no you can actually bind or
unbind whenever you want so it is under
programmer control in this in this in
this world I would assume that what you
do to get it specific to a finger sensor
in cameras that you actually just have
the plane cut descriptor the joint point
descriptor say that the receiver is the
s instance variable essentially that
essentially that's what you're doing
there's an implicit target this
construct for instance level point cut
descriptors but there's nothing special
about the constructor using variables or
anything like that is just the joint
point descriptors well that connection
right right okay so you know the
contribution here in some sense is a
simpler model of aop that doesn't really
lose anything we no longer have aspect
as a separate module construct in this
language we no longer have this notion
even of base and aspect code we just
have modules and they're just like old
modules except now they can advise each
other okay so advising basically just is
now seen as a another composition
mechanism like procedure called a can
call B or B can advise a I mean one
could even just refactor code to to
interchange advising and procedure call
if you wanted to there's no constraint
to a two story kind of story or
architecture and there's no need really
to four
kind of semi mysterious notion of
aspects as somehow modular
representations of cross-cutting
concerns what we rather see is that
aspects are just modules applied in a
particular way to modular eyes these
sort of scattered bits of code thing I
don't understand that relates to the
obliviousness which seems like a good
property is that if I is that the advice
it is a come from statement as opposed
to a go to stable yeah and so you know
if I design my system you know that
example you get with sensor and cameras
where you explicitly add the observer
pattern to each to the kick to the
sensor then when I'm looking at the
sensor code I have some feeling of that
I know what that code is doing because
it's deciding to go notify clients about
you know observers about its actions
right whereas now you know given your
system I can go ahead and grab in at any
point and say now I'm going to ramp
patrol right and so I don't understand
how you preserve it seems like for
safety you want preserves been
obliviousness I don't see in here any
mechanisms by which you force the
aspects to to allow the base coat remain
oblivious of their existence well
there's there's two problems with
obliviousness one is that um if you let
the base code writers just write their
code the way they ordinarily would they
may not write it in a way that makes it
easy to write the alphabet okay
the other problem is that aspects can
get in and do whatever the heck they
want and they can completely break the
satisfaction of you know the
specification of the object but you know
engineers are empowered to make those
sorts of decisions I mean do we want
programming languages telling us we
can't do that maybe yes maybe no that's
philosophical debate but let me talk
about this notion of obliviousness for a
second can I test your patience by
talking for just a few minutes about
obliviousness or are we are we finished
jump your net view we're done finish me
out of the room okay I mean if people
want to get up and leave that's fine I
just have a couple of slides on
obliviousness so it's been a prominent
it's been a prominent notion the idea is
you want to be able to right base code
oblivious of aspects this is a quote
this is kind of the thing that the the
mantra of this part of the community
just program like always and will be
able to add the aspects later and this
got sold in a big way to places like
DARPA right because they said oh you
write the code and now we'll add on
reliability the correctness aspect
that's been you know I mean so so so so
so it's so my favorite sort of response
is what's the aspect going to do get all
the buggy code in one module that you
know it's easy to joke about this but
there's something there is something
interesting here and there is something
actually interesting here and so we've
we've tried to we've tried to figure out
you know what what makes sense here and
what doesn't Craig you might be
completely as the story of
oblivious super classes are oblivious to
how their sub classes are going right
along an extended right and we threw
that one away a long time ago you have
to design your super classes carefully
so they can be extended well but it's
still a good option programming to
inheritance is still right so I mean
there again in that in that case a good
analogue because there's two issues
there one is you want to design so that
you can add them so that you can extend
easily you want to design base coat so
that you can write the aspects easily
the other is that you know you may want
some guarantee that the subclasses don't
break the don't brake system so there's
some notion of behavioral subtyping
there but as hola programmers there's no
unfort you know there's no enforcement
of that but we know that if we break it
which we might well want to do in some
cases say to do fault injection that we
know what we're doing okay so if you do
oblivious design this is kind of this is
kind of the the process this is actually
a little a little model of a system that
of a refactoring of an overlay network
system that some of my students and I
did here's the base code these are the
modules the main modules of the base
code then we wanted to add aspects for
protocol events and logging and various
sorts of various sorts of aspects if you
take the oblivious approach you write
the base code first and then you write
the aspects the aspects then depend on
the base code and here's some of the
problems with this design strategy
sequentiality you have to write the base
code before you write the aspect if you
want to get to market fast you'd like to
have these people writing their code at
the same time ok it's just parallel
development is impeded by this by this
notion of obliviousness you end up
dealing with complexity because the
aspect writer has to understand the base
code in order to write the aspects
there's an absence of abstraction and
they have to conform to arbitrarily ugly
base code and finally because the
aspects depend so heavily on details of
the base code they're fragile and when
the base coat evolves the aspects are
subject to be broken so this approach we
believe is not particularly optimal for
time-to-market dependability avoiding it
late integration crises or for managing
long-term lifecycle costs
torch has of course exactly the same
problems the EOS language does nothing
about this okay you need a new idea you
need a new idea okay and that idea is
the the contribution of this piece of
the work is in this notion that we call
join point interfaces okay it's just an
instance of information hiding but it
says that you have to put interfaces
between the aspect code and the base
code these interfaces though are not
typical procedural or API like
interfaces rather they're what we call
join point interfaces or JP is and what
they do is they constrain the base coat
writer to write code to expose certain
join points in certain ways and they
license aspect writers to assume that
those join points are exposed in in the
right ways okay so they define points at
which aspects can advise they can't
impose some additional semantic
constraints and what's really
interesting about these JP is as opposed
to api's is that they're cross-cutting
so i can write a JP I for example that
says across your entire system if you
want something to be laga Bowl you have
to implement it in the following
particular way so that my point cut
descriptor now matches it appropriately
ok so these JP is are cross-cutting and
non hierarchical so instead of this
picture this is the picture you
interpose these interfaces between the
base coat and the aspects and everybody
depends on the interfaces in sort of the
typical way so the cost of this approach
is that you pay some cost to define the
interface and you also incur some
opportunity cost in limiting the design
space these three the base coat authors
are in fact constraints to implement
these JP is for example but you get
benefits in all the ways that you would
expect by modularizing your system so
it's a little ironic that the core
approach of the aspect community is
non-modular in the sense that aspects
are not decoupled from base code and
this approach basically addresses that
problem so that's pretty much the end of
the end of the story
so
address this is that and everything when
you when you apply one aspect a fly
another aspect be
you have no guarantee about the orders
in which okay so I mean aspectj and also
eos provide some mechanisms for you know
constraining the order in which advice
runs there are rules about how different
aspects apply at a shared joint point so
I differ there are there is actually
some control that being said it not so
easy necessarily to reason formally
about everything that might I mean the
problem is it's like with function
composition when I have F Kentucky those
age I sort of know I have a very nice
compositional semantics and I don't I
mean I think this is more like
sequential composition than function
composition I mean that's kind of what
the semantics gets down to first you do
this piece of code and then you do this
piece of code then you do this piece of
code well this is fun as long as all the
advices is just reading data and not
writing but as soon as you have you know
as soon as you're inserting assignments
here and the aspects or so somewhat
decoupled but maybe they're writing in a
common data it seems like this is this
is just a self-modifying code where
where you just don't out with this well
you know I mean but but you know you
have the same problem with the observer
pattern right I mean this is not unique
to aspects and you know i mean my view
if this is you pay something which is
the inability to necessarily know
exactly what the behavior is when the
piece of code you're looking at runs but
you gain something as well which is
potentially much better modularity in
your in your code base and in your in
your overall design process so it's a
power tool it can be used it can be
abused if used in the right way then you
mitigate the risks and you you get the
benefits has anybody done a study to see
there really is a benefit over you know
saying doing the observer pattern are
things I mean I just haven't seen any
sort of that else people it seems very
intuitive but there's all this code that
cuts across all the stuff but is this
really a better way I think people are
still arguing about that when it comes
to 0 0 as well um so well they are
really oh uh right it's tough I agree I
mean it's very it's very hard really to
evaluate these these design design
strategies you do have you know sort of
people voting with their feet to some
degree which you know you know I mean
herd mentality isn't always the right
doesn't always give the right answer um
but I mean it looks to us that there are
some cases where in fact you're better
off it's not clear to me really how far
you can push this so I think you know
the I think I think the jury is still
out
when you pre decisis to level design you
come to have have a hierarchy so base
coat shorts level otherwise there's
second level of violence or little
advisors and so on right that's hard to
do an aspect J but not in heels right
but you chose
No
the question is what kind of structures
can you express in each of these
languages in aspectj you are largely
constrained again in the footnote to
express to level structures in EOS you
can express n level structures without
doing anything look out of the ordinary
don't impose this no levels no I mean it
what is the impression on for this
choice for not imposing these levels I
mean essentially what we've done is
we've reduced aspectj to the addition of
a new composition mechanism to the
language so in addition to function call
an event notification you now also have
advising and in EOS you're not
constrained to use that in any
particular way you can build arbitrary
advising structures so in just the way
that you can build arbitrary call graphs
instead with one of them is your
priority it would be a few reasonable
base coat then you're easily book based
ok the fill sure ok absolutely so we
don't do anything to prevent engineers
from doing that and you know they're
probably well advised to do that in most
cases
and level so if I write in a device that
says insert this logging thing at every
call anywhere right what happens to
visit advise itself as well yeah so your
point cuts typically say on any call to
to any method not within not ! within
and the name of the aspect itself output
the trace message okay so you use the
point cut composition language to
exclude basically to the case yeah yeah
accept it as a see flow you gotta be
easy to make sure when it calls the
standard library it's not tracing all
the calls to string concatenation
that yeah absolutely you can do that
exactly right so you can basically say
any call to any method within the
library that's not within any call to
any method in the library and in that
way trace all top-level calls to the
library but not any better below that
so you know I mean it's a you know at
least with respect to some of these sort
of concerns it does give you kind of an
interesting kind of expressiveness again
I think the jury's still out on this but
there's enough excitement about it and
enough mystery and enough controversy
that it seems to make sense really to
take it seriously and to try to
understand what's there maybe last
question no I mean we have we have until
noon I'm here so I just don't want to
test your patience series I mean I've
seen ok so I've seen a bunch of
presentations that you know have
examples and the inserting various login
kinds of things it's a very common
example for i'm curious what sort of
real code that using aspects looks like
both in terms of the actual descriptions
the the point cut descriptions and the
you know the size of the aspects
themselves I mean so you know logging
you know you can see it's going to go a
few lines of code if I to write to a
file option like that but but for sort
of non obvious you know types of aspects
you know how complex do they get okay in
real coup it's a good question on so in
developing and trying to test this
notion of join point interfaces we took
a essentially a 50,000 line program
which is laughably smell around here but
it's still a real program it manages a
ad hoc overlay networks this is your
gleba harris hyper caste system it's a
really interesting nice system and we
picked it as a kind of a case study for
comparing and contrasting different AO
strategies because in fact it the code
base embeds some of these classic
crocodile concerns and there are a
couple there's a bunch of logging code
scattered out across the system okay
number one number two it used the
observer pattern to allow clients of
overlay nodes to register to be notified
when certain events happen in the
overlay we thought well we would want to
replace that with some notion of
advising those actions
rather than registering for events and
there were three or four other sort of
concerns that were scattered out across
the code that we decided we'd like to
try to modularize in aspectj so the
first thing that we did in this study is
we just pulled all the code for those
concerns out of where it was put it in
aspects and essentially tried to figure
out what you know how hard would it be
to write the aspects if the base code
had been written just as it was but
without all that cross cutting stuff in
it okay so this is here are three point
cuts that we ended up having to write in
some sense to cause the code that we had
been pulled out to put be put right back
in from where we had taken it um so you
know this point cut for example I don't
know if you can read it back there says
you know any set of some stuff and
you're within some code and you know
there's a variety of things sort of
going on here it's quite complicated and
and and ugly okay and that that's the
problem with obliviousness if you let
the base coat author write the base code
however they want the aspect code author
is stuck with having to write these
complicated in point cut descriptors to
describe where they want their advice to
go back into so this gives you a little
sense of what some point cuts might look
like in a system like websphere ok so
ibm's websphere has apparently been
heavily aspect eyes and there are a
bunch of other kind of enterprise
software people out there jboss and
others who are you know pretty heavily
committed to this technology and our
building you know application servers
and that sort of thing using aspects
spring is another big one and you know
this is the kind of code this is the
kind of code you see now if you have
this notion of a joint point interface
that constrains the way in which the
base code is written then you can end up
expressing all of this stuff sort of
more like more like this because there
some regularity in the base coat you
know there's just you know a uniform way
in which certain kinds of events are are
signaled by the way the code is
structured there's no extra code in
there so there's still this sort of
quasi notion of obliviousness but it's
much easier for an outsider to say I
want things to happen at these
particular points so is it huh is it
true that if I I just changed the name
of a function I can I think for I can
have a point cut fail absolutely so as a
writer the base code actually have to
know exactly what the point cut
descriptions are in all the aspects when
I change any name is that correct
absolutely right that's right it is this
one right I was gonna say the end into
JP I okay yeah right and and and as an
aspect writer trying to advise code that
was written by some oblivious programmer
you may have to write 40 different point
cut descriptors it took as you know my
because because they're inconsistent
across the base code so here there's a
classic example in the aspect community
of the figure editor and basically the
idea here it's much like my example
you've got points in lines and the idea
is that when they change some aspect is
going to update a display on
here's what you know we think these JP I
sort of look like today the JP I says
you know here's this here's the syntax
well a couple of things about these JP
is first you define the scope you say
that the constraints imposed by this JP
I only apply to the figure element class
and its subclasses okay so if you're in
a 50 million line program you don't want
everybody to have to conform to this JP
I so the JP I says I only apply to these
elements of the base code here's the
syntax okay change signal is a point cut
that matches any execution of figure
element set or of any method of any
subclass of figure element that starts
with the name set or the execution of
any method of any figure element class
that is called move or that starts with
the word move okay and the constraint
that this JP I imposes on the base code
designer is here that change signal
this point cut is satisfied if and only
if x and only by those actions in the
code that signal you know transitions in
the abstract states of figure elements
so this basically says as the
implementer of any figure element object
if you're going to do something that
changes the state of a figure element it
has to be done in a way that matches
this point cut descriptor and the only
things that you can make match this
point cut descriptor are those things
that that satisfy this this predicate
that's just a convention right there's
nothing that's the language enforcement
well no I mean at this point at this
point it is it is a convention so it's
interesting in aspectj that there are
some and an eneos as well there are some
limited mechanisms for doing certain
kind of checking so you can in
particular you can write point gut
descriptors and any place where they're
matched the compiler will give you an
error message okaying you can use this
to do some limited checking of these
kinds of JP is and so this is an example
on that that that essentially uses
built-in constructs to check in a
limited way that um that these JP is are
actually enforced so I think that the
broader that you know the bigger answer
is yeah right checkers or do
verification have people inspect code do
testing in general but more particularly
there are some interesting opportunities
to use on to use
aspectj or yose itself to do some of
this checking so let's see if I can
decode one of these so this this
right
if you go back and look at the
constraint this this this this um one of
the things that you want is that for a
piece of advice not to call a mutator of
the thing being advised ok that's a
non-interference a non-interference on
requirement so this this piece of code
right here basically says signal an
error dynamic signal an error if there's
any call to any of the mutaters of
figure element class in the dynamic
scope of any call to any method of the
figure element class ok so a mutator is
going to cause advice to run and you
don't want the advice then to turn
around and call any of the mutaters of
the object that caused the advice to run
so this is basically a dynamic check of
a of a non-interference a requirement
for for this kind of JP I so that gives
you some sense of think broadly speaking
you're on your own but you can develop
tools and checkers and other stuff to
deal with that problem alright yeah i
think is a good point which thank the
speaker anyway one thanks thank you
thanks for having me